non pas deux heures donc hier soir mais
des débordements pourraient avoir lieu
cet après midi alors que le dispositif
de sécurité à paris s'annonce encore
important écoutez à ce sujet accéderont
une secrétaire général du syndicat
police en avant
dont le moment
ces deux derniers samedis il n'y a pas
trop de débordements sur la région
parisienne sur paris maintenant
effectivement
nos collègues des renseignements
s'attendent à quelques petits
débordements sur certaines deux villes
de province comme nantes je vais
respecter les consignes qu'ils ont
données ne pas donner le nombre
d'effectifs qui avait une technique sur
la capitale en général c'est de l'ordre
de 2500 à 3500 policière c'est un petit
peu du jamais vu autant de coton de
mobilisation pendant l'été surtout au
niveau du moins d'août en général c'est
quand même le père le plat les gens sont
plutôt en vacances on voit que les gens
vont manifester aussi sur les lieux de
vacances puisque on voit que dans le sud
de la france surtout longue et forte
mobilisation donc on voit très bien que
finalement peut-être que certains
vacanciers aussi vont manifester
effectivement on attend dans un temps
beaucoup de monde à la rentrée surtout
s'il ya d'autres annonces
gouvernementales sur d'autres sujets